here's another piece of good news
um American beer brand Bud Light knocked
four billion dollars off of its parent
company anheuser-busch's market cap this
past past week following a
pro-transgender advertisement featuring
the biological male nose known as Dylan
Mulvaney
on March 31st Anheuser-Busch had a
market capitalization of
132.38 billion dollars by April 10th the
figure had dropped to 128 billion uh uh
28.4 billion with signs of the stock
market will continue to fall
um
and uh so and we know that this is all
happening after
uh
they had this endorsement deal with
Dylan Mulvaney and some conservatives
spoke out against it
and this is great this is a great thing
and we need to keep it up
the only negative here is the
possibility that we won't
keep it up this will just be a blip on
the radar screen
and then and then conservatives we'll
just go back to buying Bud Light again
as long as we don't make that mistake
then this is a big win
as long as we stick with it it's not
hard to do
like you cut Bud Light out of your life
in a second
and it requires requires no effort and
you'll be fine like even if you like
that kind of terrible beer there are
other types that are just as cheap and
um
that you can choose instead you know I
see conservatives sometimes complaining
that this is this has been a big thing
on Twitter and on social media you have
something service complaining at the
right shouldn't have focused on this Bud
Light thing as much as it's a
distraction they say and in general they
say we shouldn't be talking about Dylan
Mulvaney because uh you know by talking
about him we've quote unquote made him
famous right like he's a he's a he is a
a monster of our own making is the logic
but that's a really lazy take and it's
and it's it's obtuse
and it's not correct
okay just like we talked about in the
open the left appoints their own Heroes
they're champions
this is what they do the left selected
Mulvaney as their mascot for
transgenderism their new mascot he's
gonna be famous no matter what we did
that's how this works if you haven't
noticed by now
the left doesn't need our help to make
someone famous they can do that all on
their own they own all of the
institutions that bestow Fame in the
first place so you think they need us to
go along with it
we could never say a word about someone
they'd still be made into a star I mean
look at uh look at Stacy Abrams
for example
the right has never had any kind of
obsession with Stacy Abrams we we've
never found her particularly interesting
or talked about her very much
uh when she runs for office obviously
but you know I don't think anyone could
accuse anyone on the right of having a
Stacy Abrams
uh Obsession and and also she's just she
has no Charisma she has no star power
she's just like a big nothing
and yet the left selected her they said
you're we're gonna make your you know
you're one of our mascots you're one of
our you're one of ours now you're you're
a star we're gonna we've decided we've
decided that you're a star and the next
thing you know she's doing TV uh cameos
and she's on all the late night shows
she's on red carpet she's going to award
shows she's you know she's uh so she's
hanging out with celebrities
and all of that happened without any of
us on the right contributing to it
because again
they own all the institutions that
bestow Fame
we could I so when when Mulvaney comes
along we can either
nod and go along silently
while the next Woman face Minstrel show
star is appointed or we can speak up and
we can State what is true and obvious
remember Phil mulvania that that thing
at the in New York the the day 365 of
the big Gala Celebration Day 365 of
quote-unquote girlhood and again
celebrities were there it was a big well
remember he started planning that
six months into his girlhood schtick
so he started planning that that was on
in the the cards before most people on
the right even took note of this guy
he already had all this funding and
support and this was already planned all
of it
um and so when they when they bring a
parade another man around and says the
woman look how great this was a woman of
the new woman of the year we have two
choices on the right we can either just
look the other way
or we can speak up and say no this is
absurd this is wrong here's why
some of us chose the latter and the
latter is the better choice
now here's the thing
we can't make Dylan Mulvaney unfamous
once the left is decided to do that with
someone we did we can't stop it we don't
own Hollywood we don't own the media
um
but we can
make someone a much more toxic and
divisive figure than he otherwise would
have been and that's what we did with
Dylan Mulvaney and it was well deserved
we can't make them unfamous we can
to use a leftist term problematize him
this is the term the left uses so to to
literally like to make to take something
that's not seen as a problem and make it
a problem
a similar thing was successfully
achieved with uh with the Hershey's dude
a few weeks ago it's a necessary tactic
in a culture War it's very necessary and
the tactic in this case is simply to say
what is true so but we are
problematizing by pointing to an actual
problem the left problematizes by making
something a problem that isn't the
problem
but we're taking something that is a
problem which in this case is the
degradation appropriation of Womanhood
and we're pointing out that no this is a
problem here's why
um
and because of that you know Bud Light
took a major hit
and again that if if we go back on it
then it doesn't mean anything it's not a
win
but if we stick with it
then I guarantee you the next the next
corporation that serves a similar
customer base to the to what Bud Light
serves we'll think twice
before doing an endorsement with Dylan
Mulvaney or anybody like that they'll
think twice about they might still do it
but we've given them something to think
about is it really worth it
[Music]
[Applause]